[Music]
ass is out everywhere on every single
console ever what are you doing what are
you literally doing check out link in
description download ass now finally as
is out in case you don't know it's a
game that I helped make together with
Armand and the great team of double
moose nice job team
for real we hope to make more games in
the future for now the game is out
everywhere check it out
support it let's do community ones cuz
they're always the most fun let's sort
by most likes my s most likes that's
cute
okay let's do wipeout at one point oh
okay obviously I played wipeout so it's
not up obvious obviously since I helped
make this game that means I'm a pro at
the game and I know how to play every
single aspect of it not a problem way
too easy
oh my god I told you I'm a pro okay
don't worry about it as you can see the
game has no glitches in it either which
is why add image come on come on Rudy
we're fine we're fine game of the year
sorry game of this set god Oh shortcut
cool game of the century everybody what
else are you going to do with your life
out if you buy this game right now you
will also lose your virginity there we
go everybody that was alright Mun no
glad we don't have a toxic fanbase so
the ink comes with a level editor it
works for any letter any platform so you
can play any level at any platform it's
a super they spent a lot of time working
on this level editor it's very intuitive
it's very easy to use do make some
levels for me to play fight robot pirate
markiplier that sounds just like what I
want oh my god it is markiplier what do
I do
oh my god she says okay oh my god
well props for being creative damn wait
someone made a markiplier robot boss
battle ok that's awesome
yeah we got another attack come on
corndog damn it damn you markiplier
seriously playing the levels that you
guys make what's the right word
I'm flabbergast why you guys silent this
is like all you do is push shitty memes
all the time but here I can actually see
that you have some talent which at least
you know I can I can appreciate you're
not completely useless after all you
know what I mean there you go screw you
market play damn it
notice how marketplace beer that doesn't
connect fully I don't have that problem
because I'm not a SOI boy that place is
something tend to switch if you play
this game moaning tennis which you might
as well just stop playing right away
please do support this game on Nintendo
switch we spent a lot of money and time
morning at Tunis am i selling the game
enough for you come on what is this a
game made for soy boys get out of here
too easy
there you go okay we blew half his
awkward beard now we just gotta blow off
his giant ego I mean his face mark apply
if you're watching just kidding JK I
love you go well fun playas eight men a
bit of fun go just go Chuck I'm alive no
I'm not how am I not beating this stupid
boss yet pathetic I take back every why
does it fly off this game is garbage I'm
sorry I'm just kidding
please support this game please okay we
got it this is the bet this is the best
vehicle in the game guys
there you go look this is the best
vehicle in this game is [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is the best vehicle in the game go
go and I will kill you there you go
sometimes you just got to switch
vehicles there you go all right well we
beat the level everybody that's great
Felix listen Sierra do what it that
basically means Felix is the best
youtuber ever in swedenland alright we
got the helicopter no problem we're just
got a respawn there oh is that supposed
to be me is that supposed that's so
offense God that doesn't even look like
me oh my god I'm never getting I can't
beat myself just kidding I do that every
day haha
I missed me stupid pooter I'm fine
how am I gonna fly enough I can't fly
enough fly wrong corndog cool we beat
another level guys that's really cool
game of this century jacksepticeye's
punch at what oh my god wait what is
happening why what a good wait someone
someone programmed punch-out will white
sorry oh my god
that is so crazy how is that possible
how how
oh I'm rolling to the sides oh my god
that is so created scream jacksepticeye
damn it damn it damn it I've gotta beat
jacksepticeye chap like what if I just
spam
I'm just gonna spam in my work in my
work damn it
hate fasiq [ __ ] ooh been to three men
every chapter Jack fun damn it I hate
you I know your moves said Jack stop
easy
[Music]
screw you
best game of the year best game of
thousand 3000 BC caveman-style damn you
got one more gameplay just play this
game honestly though so creative we made
a game work with just a level editor
people making all these cool stuff
already sewed oh wait am I supposed to
get up how I need enough I need the ass
experimental come on yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah hey it's not just my game guys
remember it's argue dammit
all right maybe the ASR is nothing good
we should probably use a character it
should be easy with the confidence all
right maybe not
ah get up get up get up get up
fine we're doing good we're good cheap
just get up there nice nice saute oh
wait what do I gotta do I gotta hit the
button right got'em you dead boy you
dead his ass boy yeah heck yeah guys
smash like right now if you like ass as
well three tips
well done making that level alright I'm
gonna play more of you guys levels so do
make some in the level editors I can't
wait to see what you guys are gonna make
I'm super impressed what you've already
created so awesome see if you can beat
my levels as well solid s yeah see if
you can beat my levels as well and check
out the game if you like ass as well
that's it for me for now brofist pretty
private is sick so when I'm taking over
you trying to get like your profits to
the face can you keep it with a pace and
I'm never gonna switch how's it going
like this when you wanna hit a flow
running like a plane I promise I will
never stop run up in the city and I'm
never gonna fly tell me when I go I'm
like whenever I'm done with this Pastor
Mike that Edgar